[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصفه الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من بيروت التي اصدر
النائب العام فيها قرارا بمنع حاكم المصرف
المركزي رياض سلامه من السفر بعد استماع
نيابه العامه الى اقواله بعد ايام من صدور
مذكرتي توقيف دوليتين في حقه
الى طهران حيث نتابع هذه الصور المباشره
على وقع تصاعد السجل مع اسرائيل بعد
تحذيرات اسرائيليه بتوجيه ضربه عسكريه
وشيكه على خلفيه انشطه طهران النوويه
والرد الايراني بانما تنشره اسرائيل
ادعاءات باطله وحرب نفسيه
وهذه الصور تردنا من موسكو التي تحذر من
حرب نوويه ان شارك الغرب في النزاع مع
اوكرانيا كلام ياتي في ظل هجمات متتاليه
على مقاطعه بيلجورود الروسيه الحدوديه
واستهداف سفينه استطلاع روسيه شمال شرقي
البوسفور
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في مؤشر على توسيع نطاق ضرب اهداف روسيه
موسكو تعلن احباطه هجوم اوكراني على احدى
سفنها الحربيه في البحر الاسود وتتوعد برد
حازم على محاولات التوغل الاوكرانيه في
بيلجورود واشنطن تجدد التاكيد على عدم
دعمها بشن هجمات داخل روسيا
مواجهات بين الجيش والدعم السريع في ثاني
ايام الهده الجيش يعلن التصدي لما وصفها
بانتهاكات الدعم السريع ويقول انه ابلغ
الجهات الراعيه للاتفاق بالخروقات قوات
الدعم السريع تتهم الجيش بشن هجمات على
مواقعها في محاور عده بالخرطوم الخارجيه
الامريكيه تقول للجزيره لا تبحث سبل
مراقبه وقف اطلاق النار ومنها استخدام
الاقمار الاصطناعيه
بعد تهديدات متزايده من تل ابيب ضد ايران
وحلفائها الجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد التعرض
احدى مسيراته لاطلاق نار من الاراضي
السوريه ويعلن عن مناورات تحاكي حربا
متعدده الجبهات مستشار الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي يتوجه الى واشنطن لبحث الملف
النووي الايراني وطهران تتهم تل ابيب
بالسعي لزياده الضغوط عليها عبر ادعاءات
باطنه
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مصير وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان وسط اشتباكات متفرقه واتهامات
متبادله لخرق الهدنه التي تختلف هذه المره
بوجود اليات مراقبه دوليه لاستطاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي الى اي درجه ساهمت اليات
مراقبه الغده في الزام الاطراف باحترامها
جاءت النتائج على النحو التالي 15%
اعتبروا ان اليات المراقبه ساهمت بدرجه
كبيره بينما قال 28% ان المساهمه محدوده
اما 57% فرعوا ان اليات المراقبه لم تساهم
اطلاقا
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلال اهل قضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا وسط صراع سياسي
قد يؤدي الى تخلف الولايات المتحده عن
سداد ديونها لاول مره في التاريخ استمرار
المفاوضات بين ديمقراطيين والجمهوريين
لحلحله ازمه سقف الدين
[موسيقى]
اذا قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان سفينه
الحربيه الروسيه ايفان خورس تعرضت لهجوم
فاشل من قبل ثلاثه زوارق مسيره اوكرانيه
في البحر الاسود عند اقترابها من مضيق
البوسفور وقال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان السفينه الحربيه كانت تحمي خطي
انابيب الغاز ترك ستريم وبلوس ستريم
اللذين ينقلان الغاز من روسيا الى تركيا
جزئيا عبر البحر الاسود ونستمرت في اداء
مهامها بعد الهجوم واكد كناشينكوف تدمير
جميع الزوارق المسيره التي هاجمت السفينه
على بعد 140 كيلومترا شمال شرقي البوسفور
بعد الهجوم الارهابي عام 2022 على انابيب
التيار الشمالي تتخذ قواتنا تدابير لحمايه
هذه المرافق فاليوم قامت القوات
الاوكرانيه بمحاوله فاشله لمهاجمه سفينه
ايفان خورس التابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود
والتي تقوم باداء مهام لضمان سلامه تشغيل
خطي انابيب الغاز التيار التركي والتيار
الازرق في المنطقه الاقتصاديه التركيه
الخالصه بثلاث زوارق مسيره عاليه السرعه
دمرت جميع زوارق العدو على بعد 140
كيلومترا شمال شرقي مضيق البسفور سفينه
ايفان خورس تواصل اداء مهامها
في هذه الاثناء قال حاكم مقاطعه بلغورود
الروسيه فايتشيسلاف جلاد ان انظمه الدفاع
الجوي اسقطت طائره مسيره اوكرانيه لدى
اقترابها من المدينه دون وقوع اصابات كما
اسقطت الدفاعات الجويه امس عددا كبيرا من
الطائرات المسيره في المقاطعه وشرح حاكم
المقاطعه الى ان طائره مسيره اخرى اسقطت
عبوات الناسفه على مبنيين اداريين في
منطقه توماروفكا ملحقه اضرارا ماديه بهما
في المقابل قال البيت الابيض انه لا يؤيد
استخدام المعدات العسكريه الامريكيه لشن
هجمات داخل روسيا وقالت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز ان القوات المواليه لاوكرانيا
استخدمت مركبات مدرعه امريكيه الصنع في
التوغل في روسيا وبحسب الصحيفه الامريكيه
فان ثلاثا على الاقل مما بدا انها مركبات
تكتيكيه امريكيه الصنع تعرف باسم ام ار اي
بي اس كانت جزءا من الهجوم عبر الحدود وان
القوات الروسيه سيطرت على اثنتين من هذه
المدرعات
الهجوم بالمسيرات المفخخه على احدى قطع
البحريه الروسيه في البوسفور يذكر بهجمات
مماثله استهدفت منشات ومواقع عسكريه اما
في عمق الاراضي الروسيه او خارجها منذ
بدايه الحرب في اوكرانيا فبراير 2022
ميناء سباستوبول الميناء الرئيسي لاسطول
البحر الاسود الروسي تعرض لهاجمات متكرره
باسراب من الطائرات المسيره المفخخه اخر
هذه الهجمات كان نهايه ابريل الماضي واحدث
اضرارا جسيمه ادت الاحتراق اربعه
على الساحل الغربي لشبه جزيره القرم تقع
قاعده ساكي الجويه وهي مركز رئيسي تستخدمه
القوات الروسيه لشن هجمات ضد اوكرانيا في
اغسطس الماضي هاجمت طائرات مسيره القاعده
الجويه الروسيه قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان انفجارات عده هزت القاعده بسبب انفجار
مستودعات الذخيره لكن الجيش الاوكراني اكد
انه هو من استهدف القاعده ماده لتدمير عشر
طائرات حربيه روسيه من طراز سو اربعه
وعشرين
مطلع اكتوبر الماضي هز القرم انفجار ضخم
تبين لاحقا ان الهدف كان جسر القرم الذي
يربط شبه الجزيره بروسيا ويوصف بانه احد
اعظم انجازات بوتين في شبه الجزيره واحد
اهم طرق الامداد العسكري للقوات الروسيه
القواعد العسكريه في عمق الاراضي الروسيه
لم تكن بمنئ عن الهجمات من ذلك الهجوم
بطائره مسيره على قاده انجلز الجويه في
مقاطعه السيراتوف وهي القاعده الرئيسيه
للقاذفات الاستراتيجيه الروسيه وتقع على
بعد 500 كلم شرق الحدود مع اوكرانيا
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من كييف اوليك مساعد
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني السابق ومن موسكو
ينضم الينا فاسيلي فاتيجاروف الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي والضابط الاحتياط في
الجيش الروسي مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك سيد
اوليكس في كييف لطالما تمسكت اوكرانيا
بمقوله انها ترد الهجوم الروسي على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هل تغيرت هذه
الاستراتيجيه
تقوم باعلانات متناسبه مع الاهداف التي
تصل لها في بعض الاحيان فعلا كان من
الواضح ان هناك اعمال عسكريه من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه كيف كانت لا تعترف ولا
تستعجل باعلان مسؤوليتها ولكن في احوال
اخرى عندما كان هذا يتناسب مع السياسه
الاعلاميه العسكريه كانت كيف تؤكد بشكل
مباشره او غير مباشر انها اعمال من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه ولكن نحن نسالك من
منطلق ما يحدث الان في بلغورود وهذا
الهجوم على السفينه الحربيه الروسيه في
البحر الاسود قرب البوسفور هل هذا يعني
حدوث هذه الهجمات هل يعني ان
الهجوم او العمليات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
باتت تشمل يعني امكنه خارج اوكرانيا
ما حدث في برجراد تم بايدي مواطنين روس
وكل
كل
المتدخلين في هذا الشان هم رؤوس ودخلوا من
الحدود الروسيه ولم يتدخل فيها اي
جندي اوكراني اما بالنسبه للهجمات على
السفينه الحربيه الروسيه حتى وان لم تعترف
اوكرانيا به مسؤوليتها من المفهوم
وبالغالب هذا يصب في مصلحه القوات
الاوكرانيه وهو هدف مشروع
لذلك السفن العسكريه الروسيه هي هدف شرعي
ممكن تدميره في اثناء الحرب
هذه اهداف مشروعه بالنظر الى ان اوكرانيا
تتعرض لهجوم روسي كيف ترد
المتحدث
قد لا يكون صادق ان السفينه الروسيه في
البحر الاسود هي سفينه حراسه للمياه
التركيه ومياه البحر الاسود
عدا عن ذلك هذه السفينه مسؤوله عن تامين
اتفاق الحبوب التي قامت روسيا باطالته
وتمديده لفتره ابعد بالرغم من ان الشروط
الروسيه لم تنفذ حتى الان
وبالعلم ان السياسيين الاوكرانيين لا
يتحملون المسؤوله التي تقع على عاتقهم
اساس اعتمادا على هذا الاتفاق ان اتفاق
الحبوب تم تمديده وبالرغم من هذا
هوجمت هذه السفينه
اذا ممكن ان نعتبره هجوما ارهابيا من حسن
الحظ ان هذا الهجوم تم صده تماما علما انه
كان على مسافه 140
كيلومتر في المياه التي تعتبر تابعه لبحر
باسفور
عدو كان يستهدف هذه السفينه بالرغم من هذا
سيد غسيلي
انت
وعدد من المسؤولين الروسي يتحدثون سيد
باسيلي هل تسمعني انت وعدد من المسؤولين
الروسي يتحدثون عن التصدي لهذه الهجمات
هذه الهجمات التي تحدث خارج ارض الميدان
في اوكرانيا هل فاجات روسيا
لا يعتبرون مفاجاه لاننا نعلم اننا نتعامل
مع دوله ارهابيه ونعلم ونتوقع من اوكرانيا
اي شيء
وبسبب استعدادنا نحن نقوم بصدد هذه
الهجمات بنجاح دون اي ضياع او دون ان نفقد
اي شيء سيد
تقول ان هذه اهداف مشروعه كما ذكرت ولكن
اتى يعني عدم الدعم من البيت الابيض اليوم
الولايات المتحده تقول انها لا تؤيد هجمات
خارج الميدان في اوكرانيا وبالتالي كيف
يمكن ان تتعامل السلطات الاوكرانيه مع هذا
التحفظ من جانب الولايات المتحده والدول
الداعمه لاوكرانيا في الغرب
في الواقع المساله الوحيده هنا
بالنسبه للحكومه الاوكرانيه هي مجموعه
العسكريين الروس الذين دخلوا الى
واستخدموا سيارات امريكيه من نوع هامرز
وهذا قد يقدر على انه
مخالفه للوعود الاوكرانيه بان الاسلحه
والمعدات الامريكيه لن تستخدم في هجمات ضد
روسيا ولكن كما اعترف بعض الجنود من هذه
الفرق الروسيه التي هاجمت ان هذه المعدات
والسيارات خطفت
وحصلوا عليها بعد الهجوم على قوات روسيه
لذلك هذه مساله اعتقد انها صغيره ولن تفسد
الود بين واشنطن وكيف
سيد فاسيلي ماذا عن الرد الروسي ويتوعد
وزير الدفاع برد حازم وشديد في حال تكرر
الهجوم على الاراضي الروسيه ما نوع هذا
الرد الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه
الواقع نحن نقوم بعمليه عسكريه خاصه
ولدينا اهداف محدده قام بتحديدها الرئيس
وهي
القضاء على النظام النازيع سلاحه في
اوكرانيا وحتى لا يكون هناك اي تهديدات من
هذه الاراضي نحن نقوم بالاهداف الموضوعه
امام العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
وسوف ننجح بجميع هذه الاهداف مرحله بعد
مرحله واي محاولات للهجوم او لاي عدوان
سوف يتم صدها وقد يكون
الرد معاكس تماما وهذا شيء طبيعي لتحقيق
جميع اهداف العمليه العسكريه الخاصه شكرا
لكم
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي والضابط
الاحتياط في الجيش الروسي من موسكو
واوليكسي منك مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
السابق ضيفنا من كيف
في فقره في المتابعه نسلط الضوء على
استراتيجيه دفاعيه جديده للنيتو على خلفيه
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ونسال ضيف الحصاد
عن اهم ملامحها
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات
الدعم السريع بانتهاك الهدنه المعلنه وقال
الجيش انه ابلغ الجهات الراعيه للاتفاق
من وصفها بالمليشيا المتمرده لم تستجب لاي
من مطالب الهدنه واكد الجيش التزامه
بالمحافظه على الهدى الانسانيه دون
التفريط في حقه بالدفاع عن النفس والدوله
وفق قوله
في المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع الجيش
بخرق الهدنه الانسانيه وقصف مواقعها في
عده محاور وقالت قوات الدعم السريع انها
ملتزمه بالهنه الانسانيه المعلنه تقديرا
للظرف الانساني ودعت من وصفتهم
بالانقلابيين الى الالتزام بالهدنه
الانسانيه واحترام اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
هذا واكد المتحدث الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه سامويل ان بلاده تراقب الوضع في
السودان عن كثب وستبحث مع الاطراف اي
انتهاكات تحدث
اضافرت في مقابله مع الجزيره ان الولايات
المتحده لديها امكانيه لمراقبه وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان عبر الاقمار الاصطناعيه
لدينا الامكانيه لنراقب بعض الاماكن عبر
الاقمار الثنائيه عبر التواصل مع الاطراف
المدنيه السودانيه نحن مازال في تواصل مع
كل الاطراف المدنيه لان ليس من الممكن ان
نكون فقط في تواصل مع الاطراف
قوه المسلحه الجيش
السودانية لازم نكون في تواصل مع الاطراف
المدنيه ونحن نجمع كل معلومات منها ومن
الاطراف السودانيه وايضا من الاقمار
الثنائيه
بمرور الساعات تتهاوى هدنه السودان
الجديده بدل ان تتماسك من الخروق التي
المت بها مبكرا انها في اليوم الثاني تبدو
كسابقاتها عائله الى الانهيار رغم استناد
وقف اطلاق النار هذه المره الى اليه رقابه
لقد تجددت الاشتباكات في عده مناطق
بالخرطوم بينها ام درمان حيث اسقطت قوات
الدعم السريع طائره حربيه للجيش السوداني
اوضحت مقاطع مصوره حطامها وسط النار
والدخان كما اعلنت الدعم السريع اسرها احد
الطيارين اللذين تمكنا من القفز من
المقاتله وقد جاء حادث ام درمان في اعقاب
تحليق كفيف للطائرات وقصف عنيف بالمدافع
والدبابات في المنطقه
انفجارات قويه دوت ايضا في مناطق شرق
النيل وكافوري بمدينه بحري تزامنا مع
اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع في احياء بوسط الخرطوم بينما اكد
الجيش استعاده مطابع سك العمله غربيه
العاصمه من سيطره من وصفهم بالمتمردين
الذين اتهمهم بنهب مخسون الدوله من النقد
واحتياط بنك السودان من الذهب
كان من المفترض ان تستمر الهده الجديده
اسبوعا وهي برعايه ومراقبه امريكيه سعوديه
حتى ان واشنطن لوحت بمحاسبه منتهكيها وفرض
عقوبات قاسيه عليهم ومع ان تطورات الساعات
الاخيره في الخرطوم لا تؤشر الى اي التزام
او ارتداع فقد اعتبر منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
جون كيربي ان وقف اطلاق النار ما يزال
صامدا الى حد كبير رغم الانباء عن وقوع
اشتباكات وتزداد بذلك حيره السودانيين وهم
تحت القصف من تلك الحدود الفاصله بين نجاح
الهدنه وانهيارها لكن انتهاك الهدنه الذي
يتريث السياسيون في الاقرار به كان صداه
سريعا في اروقه الامم المتحده بجنيف
ما نشهده اليوم في السودان يدمي القلب انا
اتحدث مع السودانيين وعلى تواصل معهم
وكانت تلك مهمه الاولى كنت في السودان ولا
استطيع ان اتخيل الحياه في الخرطوم في هذه
الاثناء لذلك فان التضامن يجب ان يكون مع
الشعب السوداني
والمشهد اكثر سوءا بالارقام اذ اعلنت
منظمه الهجره الدوليه نزوح اكثر من مليون
شخص داخل السودان منذ اندلاع القتال منتصف
ابريل الماضي كما لجا نحو ثلاثمائه وعشرين
الفا اخرين الى دول مجاوره وكثير منهم ما
يزالون عالقين على المعابر وفي مخيمات
ايواء تفتقر لابسط مستلزمات العيش
من جنوب الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
الطاهر المرضي الطاهر ماذا عن التطورات
الميدانيه في الساعات الماضيه
النعم التطورات المدنيه في ساعات
اشتباكات عنيفه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع وخاصه في مدينه ام درمان
التي شهدت اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله
وكذلك بالطيران على اثر ذلك اعلى النت
قوات الدعم السريع انها اسقطت طائره حربيه
سودانيه في سماء مدينه توم درمان ثم امتدت
هذه الاشتباكات اللي في شرق النيل حيث كان
هنالك
الدخان من مختلفه بالاضافه الى الاشتباكات
كانت في الخرطوم وفي جنوب الخرطوم اذن في
اليوم الثالث للهدنه شهدت انهيار كامل من
هدنه كانت متماسكه في يومها الاول والثاني
ثم انهارت في اليوم الثالث وهذا ما وضع
التحدي كبير امام لجنه الرقابه كان من
المتوقع ان تكون هذه الهدنه في المرحله
الثانيه لاتفاق جده ان تكون تتميز عن بقيه
الهدن السابقه بانها لديه فيها لجنه
للمراقبه مكونه من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والسعوديه ومن طرفي النزاع
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ولكن
الذي حدث اليوم كان هنالك تبادل
للالتهامات بين الطرفين حيث اتهم الجيش
السوداني قوات الدعم السريع بخرق الهدنه
ثم عاد واصلا وقال انه استعاد هذا الموقع
واعتبر ان ذلك هو دفاع عن النفس هو تطور
جديد ما كان ينبغي للقوات الدعم السريع ان
تخطوه بموجب هذا الاتفاق ولكن قوات الدعم
السريع اتهمت الجيش السوداني بخرق الهدنه
وقام بالهجوم على مواقع مختلفه على كل
نوعين كانت النتيجه في تبدل هذه الاتهامات
فان الاشتباكات قد حدثت بالفعل وان
الالتزام الحرفي لم ينفذ باتفاق جده
الاخير خاصه وان الكل كان ينتظر ان يكون
هذا الاتفاق هو بدايه حقيقيه ولبنه
للوصول الى اتفاق
لوقف اطلاق النار وان يكون ذلك ايضا بدايه
جيده لتقديم المساعدات الانسانيه لعدد
كبير من المتضررين شكرا لك مراسلنا الطاهر
المرضي من جنوب الخرطوم
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني المختص في
الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه مرحبا بك سيد
اسامه اذا اشتباكات عنيفه بالاسلحه
الثقيله نتحدث عن اسقاط طائر اليوم هل
سقطت هذه الهدنه
هذه الهدنه منذ بدايتها يعني جرت في
مفاوضات ليست جديده يعني هي
هنالك تجارب سابقه في السودان لمثل هذه
المفاوضات التي تجري يعني هي في الاصل
تكون لتخفيف حده
العدائيات وكسر دائره العنف
واذا نجحت في هدنه مؤقته تفتح الباب
لمفاوضات طويله المدى يمكن ان تؤدي الى حل
سياسي تمت هذه في عام 2001 في جنوب كردفان
وفي ديسمبر تم توقيع هدنه شبيهه بهذه
كل البنوك تقريبا الموجوده في اتفاق الجده
للهدنه هي نفس البنود مكرره من جديد من
اتفاق يعني واقفه العدائيات بين الحركه
الشعبيه وحكومه السودان في عام 2001 لكن
ربما هذه المره كان هناك امل اكبر لان
يعني المفاوضات حدثت في جده كان هناك
انخراط مباشر للسعوديه والولايات المتحده
في هذه المفاوضات لكن العنصر الناقص هو
التوصيف الخطا للصراع الحالي يعني حركه
الدعم السريع او جيش الدعم السريع هو ليس
حركه مطلبيه وليس حركه سياسيه
عندما نجحت واتفاقيه وقف العدائيات في
جبال النوبه لان هذه حركه سياسيه مطلبيه
لها قياده سياسيه ولها قياده ميدانيه يمكن
ان تلتزم به لكن الدعم السريع مجرد قوات
كانت تحت السيطره للجيش السوداني وتمر
يعني وصف التمرت هنا وصف اكاديمي اي انها
خرجت من القياده والسيطره وحاولت
الاستيلاء على الحب بعد فشل الهدف السياسي
وانتشار الواسع لهذه القوات في في ولايه
الخرطوم بمساحه 23 الف كيلو متر مربع هذه
القوات الان فقدت الهدف السياسي فقدت
الهدف العسكري الذي يمكن ان تقاتل به فقدت
القياده والسيطره
وفقدت التواصل بين مجموع قياداتها لذلك من
الصعب جدا ان تنجح مثل هذه الهدنه مثل هذه
المفاوضات في فرض هدنه على الارض ماذا بعد
ما حصل اليوم
الذي اتوقعه اليوم انه كان هنالك تخطيط
لهجوم متزامن في مواقع اساسيه للجيش من
اجل تغيير مجرى العمليات العسكريه المجرى
العملياتي على الارض ومحاوله ايجاد نصر
حقيقي على الارض لكن كما قلت ضعف القياده
والسيطره تشتت القوات وعدم قدرتها على
الحشد الكبير يعني الهجوم المتزامن كان
سيكون على وادي سيدنا القاعده الجويه على
المهندسين وعلى سلاح المدرعات
فشل حتى في تزامن الهجوم تزامن الهجوم
يعني شل قدره الطيران على الحركه في هذه
المساحه الواسعه ولكن ماذا بعد يعني هذا
التقويد الكبير للهدنه الذي حدث اليوم
ايضا يغيب هنا الدوره السياسي لانه
الحرب قرار سياسي وايقاف الحرب هو عمل
سياسي وليس عسكري الحرب لا توقفها الجيوش
يوقفها السياسيون نحن في صراع سياسي كبير
منذ بدايه هذه الحرب كل قوانه سياسيه
مشغوله بالقاء اللوم على الاخرين بدل
الخروج
وتحمل المسؤوليه وتحمل مسؤوليه الشعب الذي
يتعرض الان للقتل والنهب والترويع
والاغتصاب والجرائم بكل انواعها في
الخرطوم كان يجب ان تقف هذه القوه
السياسيه موقف تقود البلاد برؤيه سياسيه
يمكن ان توقف الحرب شكرا جزيلا لك اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديميه السوداني المختص في
الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه ضيفنا هنا في
استديو الحصاد شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى ملف التصعيد الاسرائيلي الايراني بعد
تهديدات متزايده من تل ابيب ضد طهران
وحلفائها قال الناطق باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان مسيره تابعه للجيش تعرضت
لاطلاق نار من اسلحه خفيفه من داخل
الاراضي السوريه عندما كانت في مهمه جمع
معلومات اعتياديه حيث ردت قوات الجيش
باطلاق نيران اسلحه رشاش نحو المنطقه التي
رصد منها اطلاق النار ولم تتعرض للمسيره
لاي اضرار وواصلت مهمتها بحسب تصريحات
الجيش الاسرائيلي
واكد رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي هرتز
هاليزي ان تل ابيب مستعده للقتال على
حدودها الشماليه ولا تطور جاهزيتها هناك
كل يوم مشيرا الى ان حزب الله يحاول تحدي
اسرائيل دون الانجرار الى حرب
ما غاب زيرات معركه على الجبهه الشماليه
ستكون صعبه وسنعرف كيف نتعامل معها وفي
لبنان ستكون اصعب سبعه اضعاف وبالنسبه
لحزب الله اصعب من ذلك بكثير بالنظر الى
الوضع الاقتصادي والاجتماعي الصعب في
لبنان
وقد اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي انه سيبدا
الاسبوع المقبل مناورات عسكريه شامله
تحاكي حربا على جبهات عده بما فيها جبهه
سوريا ولبنان وافاد مراسلنا ان المناورات
ستحاكي حالتي الهجوم والدفاع وستشارك فيها
قوات بريه وبحريه وجويه وستختبر جاهزيه
الجيش ومستوى تنسيق بين اذرعه المختلفه
نقل موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين
وامريكيين قولهم انهم من المتوقع ان يصل
كل من مستشار الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ساعي هانجبي ووزير الشؤون الاستراتيجيه
الاسرائيلي الى واشنطن الاسبوع المقبل
لاجراء محادثات بشان البرنامج النووي
الايراني والمساعي الامريكيه للدفع باتجاه
اتفاق سلام بين اسرائيل والسعوديه ونقل
موقع اكسيوس عن مسؤول اسرائيلي ان نتنياهو
يامل ان يؤدي تعليق التعديلات القضائيه
والمفاوضات مع المعارضه الى توجيه الرئيس
جو بايدن دعوه لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
لزياره البيت الابيض
في الجانب الايراني قال رئيس منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه محمد اسلامي ان اسرائيل
تحاول تشديد الضغط على ايران عبر شن حرب
نفسيه عليها وطرح ادعاءات باطله منذ سنوات
اضاف اسلامي تعليقا على الاتهامات الموجهه
الى طهران بشان بناء منشاه نوويه في جبال
زاغروس ان هذه الاتهامات باطله واسرائيل
تكررها كلما مرت بظروف سيئه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
في مزيد من الاخبار عبر العالم فازت
الكتله الاسلاميه الذراع الطلابي لحركه
حماس في انتخابات جامعه بيرزيت برام الله
احدى اكبر الجامعات الفلسطينيه واهمها
للعام الثاني على التوالي فقد حصدت الكتله
الاسلاميه 25 مقعدا مقابل 20 مقعدا لحركه
الشبيبه الزراعه الطلابيه لحركه فتح وسته
مقاعد لكتله القطب الطلابي التي تمثل
الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين وجاء فوز
كتله حماس الطلابيه في بيرزيت بعد اسبوع
من فوزها بمجلس طلبه جامعه النجاح في
نابلس للمره الاولى منذ سنوات وكانت
الشبيبه الفتحاويه قد فازت قبل اسابيع
بمجلس طلبه جامعه بيت لحم في الانتخابات
التي لم تشارك بها كتله حماس الطلابيه كما
فازت الشبيبه الطلابيه في انتخابات جامعتي
الخليل
والخليل والبولتك
من جانبه قال اسماعيل هنيه رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحماس ان فوز الكتله الاسلاميه في
جامعتي بيرزيت والنجاح كبرى الجامعات
الفلسطينيه تاكيد على تمسك الجيش
الفلسطيني الشعب الفلسطيني عفوا بخيار
المقاومه واكد هنيه في تصريحات له ان
الجامعات ليست مجرده مؤسسات اكاديميه بل
هي معاقل ثوره تاريخيه وميزان قوه وصانعه
قيادات مختلف الاتجاهات على حد تعبيره
اعلنت السعوديه وكندا الاتفاق على تعيين
سفيرين جديدين واستئناف العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بينهما بعد تعليقها اثرى خلاف
في عام 2018 وقالت الخارجيه السعوديه انه
في ضوء مباحثات بين ولي العهد السعودي
ورئيس الوزراء الكندي في نوفمبر الماضي
ورغبه من الجانبين في عوده العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين البلدين على اساس
الاحترام المتبادل والمصالح المشتركه تقرر
اعاده مستوى العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
الرياض واتاوا الى وضعها السابق من جهه
اكدت الخارجيه الكنديه التوافق على عوده
العلاقات مع السعوديه الى سابق عهدها
واعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الكنديه ان كلا من
البلدين سيعين سفيرا لدى الاخر
اكد حاكم ولايه فلوريدا روند سانتس تقديم
اوراق ترشحه رسميا للانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه عن الحزب الجمهوري ويعتبر
ديسانتس المنافسه الابرز
لكسب ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري وسينافس الفائز
في الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري
المرشح الذي يختارها الحزب الديمقراطي وفي
هذه الحاله هو الرئيس جو بايدن يراهنوا
الكثير من المحافظين على ديسانس البالغ
اربعه واربعين عاما خصوصا بعد اعاده
انتخابه حاكما لفلوريدا في نوفمبر الماضي
باغلبيه مريحه وستبدا الانتخابات
التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوري في يناير 2024
على ان يجرى الاقتراع الرئاسي بين
الفائزين بترشيح الحزبين الديمقراطي
وجمهوري في نوفمبر من العام المقبل
[موسيقى]
نبقى في الولايات المتحده حيث قال رئيس
مجلس النواب كيفن مكارسي انه سيرسل فريق
المفوضين الى البيت الابيض لانهاء
المحادثات الخاصه برفع سقف الدين الامريكي
قبل انتهاء مهله السداد مشددا على ان
تحقيق التقدم في المفاوضات امر ممكن
سارسل فريق التفاوضيه الى البيت الابيض في
محاوله لانهاء المفاوضات ما يزال هناك
العديد من نقاط الخلاف بيننا لا يبدو
الامر بهذه الصعوبه اعتقد انه بامكاننا
تحقيق تقدم وامنوا ان نحقق ذلك
قبل اكثر من قرن وتحديدا في عام
1917 قرر الكونغرس الامريكي تحديد السقف
الاقصى الذي يمكن للحكومه استدانته لكي
تتمكن من تغطيه العجز بين ايراداتها
ونفقاتها ويجري ذلك عبر طرح السندات
الحكوميه للبيع تحتاج الحكومه في حال وصول
الدين العام الى السقف المحدد الى موافقه
الكونجرس اي مجلسين نواب والشيوخ لرفعه
لكي تتمكن من الافتراض من جديد منذ عام
1960 رفع سقف الدين تسعه وسبعين مره وكان
ذلك يتم بشكل شبه روتيني رغم ما يحيط به
من سجالات في التاسع عشر من يناير الماضي
وصلت البلاد الى سقف الدين البالغ واحد
وثلاثين تريليونا و400 مليار دولار لكن
الكونغرس ورغم المفاوضات المستمره بين
اداره بايدن الديم
والاغلبيه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب يعجز
حتى اليوم عن التوصل الى اتفاق بشان رفع
سقف الدين العام ما يعني ان الولايات
المتحده ستكون للمره الاولى في التاريخ
امام سيناريو العز عن الوفاء بالتزاماتها
الماليه والتخلف عن سداد ديونها لكن ما
تداعيات ذلك ان حصل يجمع كثير من
الاقتصاديين الامريكيين ان هذه الازمه
ستلحق ضررا فادحا بسمعه الولايات المتحده
وتفقد نظامها المالي موثوقيته الدوليه وقد
تتسبب الهزات الارتداديه لهذا الزلزال
المالي الوشيك في احداث ازمه اقتصاديه
عالميه لا سيما مع الضرر الذي سيلحق بسوق
السندات وارتفاع الفوائد على الاقتراض
وتضرر البنوك الامريكيه ذات الامتدادات
الدوليه التي تعد من اكبر المقرضين
للحكومه فضلا عن العجز عن تامين الاموال
اللازمه لرواتب الموظفين وخدمات الضمان
الاجتماعي والرعايه الصحيه وغيرها من اوجه
النفقات الحكوميه كما ان الاحتمالات لحصول
ركود حاد في الاقتصاد الامريكي ستزيد بشكل
كبير الامر الذي سيكون له حتما ارتدادات
عالميه وسط توقعات بان تفقد سوق العمل
الامريكيه اكثر من سته ملايين فرصه
وارتفاع البطاله لمعدلات قياسيه
حول هذا الموضوع معنا من نيويورك
استاذه الاقتصادي بجامعه ماسد شوستس سيد
ريتش مرحبا بك ما الذي يمنع حتى الان من
التوصل الى اتفاق بين الجمهوريين
وديمقراطيين على هذه المساله
[موسيقى]
الاساسيه تكمن في مستوى الانقسام السياسي
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والذي
اصبح من المستحيل ادارته فمن جهه لديك
الحزب الجمهوري
والمدفوع بهدف اساسي واحد وهو عدم رفع
الضرائب على الشركات الكبرى والاغنياء
ولاجل تفادي فرض هذه الضرائب يطالبون بان
الحكومه
تقطع وتخفف الانفاق على الناس بشكل عام
وعلى الفقراء وعلى الانفاق على الرعايه
الصحيه التي تذهب لعامه الشعب اما الحزب
الديمقراطي والذي يعتمد على هؤلاء الناس
يرفضوا ما يريدوا الجمهوريين عمل له وعلى
العكس
الديمقراطيون اقتراض المزيد من المال هم
لا يتفقان اذن
الديمقراطيون يريدون المزيد من الاقتراض
والجمهورين يقولون عكس ذلك لكي يضمنوا ان
اي ضرائب تفرض على الاغنياء هذه
قضيه نظريه قبيحه وهي نوع من المسرح
السياسي الامريكي تجعل الشعب الامريكي
يعاني بين مطرقه وسندان المغالبيه من
الشعب الامريكي لا يريدون هذا المال طيب
سيد ولف كيف يمكن الوصول الى اتفاق ما
النقطه المشتركه التي يمكن عندها ان يلتقي
كل من الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين من اجل
معالجه هذه المساله مساله الدين
من الممكن ان يتفق مثل ما حصل في الماضي
لان ازمه سقف الديون هذه تكررت ادت مرات
على مدى العشرين عاما الماضيه من التاريخ
الامريكي وفي كل مره الحال كان هكذا تخفف
وتقطع الانفاق على الفقراء على امل ان لا
يكون كذلك كثيرا لكنك لا ترفع الضرائب على
الشركات والاغنياء وتحل المشكله
بالمزيد والمزيد من الاقتراض الخطوره هذه
المره تكمن في ان الولايات المتحده هي من
الان اكبر بلد عليه ديون في العالم وانها
استمرت في اقتراض المال فان الخوف بانه
عاجلا ام اجلا المزيد من البلدان
ستفقدوا ثقتها بالوقت المتحده ولن تقرضها
المال الحكومه الامريكيه وهذا سيكون مشكله
خطيره لكن لا توجد ايه مؤشرات على ان
الانقسام في الواقع السياسي الامريكي عدا
عن تكرار هذه المسرحيه بنفس المالات التي
رايناها في كل مره في السابق بالتذكير نحن
نتحدث عن 31
تريليون دولار تقريبا هو حجم الدين
الامريكي اشكرك ريتشارد ووف استاذه
الاقتصاد بجامعه
[موسيقى]
قال المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات التركيه ان
عدد الناخبين الذين ادلوا باصواتهم في
الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات في الخارج
وصل الى اكثر من مليون و800 الف ناخب اضاف
المجلس ان الانتخابات في الخارج جرت في
151 بعث دبلوماسيه تركيه موزعه على ثلاث
وسبعين دوله
المغتربون الاتراك رقم مهم في معادله
الفوز في دور ثاني للانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه يعودون مره اخرى للتصويت في ثلاث
وسبعين دوله تعددهم اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
واربعمائه الف ناخب تركي المسجل شارك منهم
نحو 54% في الدوري الاول للانتخابات وتقدم
اردوغان حاصلا على نحو 57 ونصف في المئه
من الاصوات متبوعا بمرشح المعارضه كمال
كريجدار اوغلو بنحو 40% تصويت الخارج في
تفاصيله حمل اكثر من دلاله خصوصا في دول
بعينها شكلت وعاء انتخابيا اذ يعيش غالبيه
المغتربين الاتراك غربيه اوروبا وكانت
المانيا الوعاء الابرز للناخبين بنحو
مليون ونصف مليون ناخب منح نحو ثلثي
الناخبين فيها اصواتهم لاردوغان بينما حاز
كلجدار اوغلو على نحو ثلث الاصوات ارجع
محللون في وسائل اعلام غربيه مثل صحيفتي
النتيجه
الى عوامل بينها استقرار العمال المهاجرين
في الستينيات حيث كان الاتراك الاوائل
الذين قدموا الى المانيا في الغالب من
سكان المناطق الريفيه المحافظه في
الاناضول وليس بعيدا دعم نحو 63% من
الناخبين الاتراك في المانيا عام 2017
التعديلات الدستوريه التي اقترحها اردوغان
لم تتخلف فرنسا عن جارتها المانيا مانحه
تفوقا مماثلا لاردوغان بنحو ثلثي الاصوات
مع حاله الشد والجذب التي اتطبعت علاقات
هذا البلد بالتركيا برر محللنا في الصحف
الفرنسيه مثل لو فيغارو النتيجه بشعبيه
اردوغان بين اجيال متلاحقه من المهاجرين
المولودين في فرنسا جاء ابائهم من مناطق
اكثر محافظه في وسط وشمال الاناضول اضافه
الى دور اردوغان على المستوى الدولي حتى
شبهته بدور الرئيس الفرنسي السابقون هذا
الارتباط يوجد في دول اوروبيه اخرى
الفرنسيه
مثل النمسا وهولندا وبلجيكا التي كما
تظهره الارقام صوتت لصالح اردوغان بشكل
مريح وبفريق مع منافسه بالمجمل باللون
الاحمر الدول التي منح فيها الاتراك في
الخارج التفوق
خصوصا في اوروبا الشرقيه وروسيا واسرائيل
وبالبرتقال دول صوتت لصالح اردوغان بينها
دول غربيه اوروبا والدول العربيه على
الامارات وسلطنه عمان لكن الصوره تبقى غير
كامله فالاهم يرتبط بالثقل الانتخابي اذ
ان 5 دول فقط في اوروبا الغربيه وهي
المانيا وفرنسا وهولندا وبلجيكا والنمسا
تمثل نصف عدد الناخبين تقدم فيها اردوغان
وشكلت لوحدها نحو 83% من اصواته وكان
حصاده اقل في دول مثل الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا اللتين صوت فيها الاتراك بنسب
تروحت بين
79% لصالح كريجدار اوغلو بينما كانت
الفجوه بين المرشحين اقل في استراليا
اختلف تصويت الناخبين الاتراك في الخارج
يلتقي الجميع في انتمائهم لوطن واحد لكن
بدت للمغتربين اولويات مختلفه عن مواطنيهم
في بلدهم الام ولهم اسبابهم ودوافعهم التي
صنعت وجهه اصواتهم
[موسيقى]
بعد 15 شهرا على بدء حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا وقبل حوالي شهر من قمه قادته في
فيلم يسعى عاصمه ليتوانيا يعزز حلف شمال
الاطلسي دفاعاته ويعدل خططه لحمايه جميع
اعضاء فكيف يبدو المشهد في استونيا
الخاصره الشرقيه للحلف تجري دول الناتو
تدريبات تتضمن شن هجوم محمول جوا لقوات
امريكيه وعمليه انزال ليليه لعناصر من
مشاه البحريه البريطانيه وانزال وحدات
كوماندوس من المظليين الفرنسيين التدريبات
التي اطلق عليها اسم العاصفه الربيعيه
تاتي في اطار استراتيجيات دفاعيه جديده
للحلف هدفها تعزيز الانتشار بسرعه كبيره
في مهله قصيره جدا لجيوش الدول الواقعه
على خط الجبهه وتشكل نقطه دفاع متقدمه
حلف شمال الاطلسي رد حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا بنشر اربع مجموعات تكتيكيه جديده
في سلوفاكيا والمجر ورومانيا وبلغاريا
اضافه الى اربع مجموعات شكلها في بولندا
ودول البلطيق وتعتزم دول الحلف الان تعزيز
عدد قواتها المنتشره في دول البلطيق
الثلاث لاتفيا واستونيا
بالاضافه الى بولندا لتصبح بحجم لواء ما
يعني حشد الاف الجنود الاضافيين حيث ومتى
تدعو الضروره يفترض ان يصدق قاده الحلف في
فيلينيوس على خطط اكثر تفصيلا توضح كيفيه
الدفاع عن كل منطقه في حال تعرضها لهجوم
مع ذكر عدد القوات والدول الاصل ومواقع
الانتشار
استعدادات النت لا تتوقف على تدريبات
العاصفه الربيعيه ولا على عمليات الانتشار
الجديده التي ستتطلب حتما مبالغ ماليه
وموارد وقوات بل ثمه خطوه شهدتها الساعه
الماضيه وصفت باستعراض قوه لحلف شمال
الاطلسي فقد وصلت حامله الطائرات
الامريكيه جيرل فورد وهي اكبر سفينه حربيه
في العالم الى اوسلو وقد اقيمت منطقه حظر
جوي وبحري كبير حول هذه السفينه
هي النسخه الاولى من الجيل الجديد لحاملات
الطائرات وتعمل بالدفع النووي ويمكن
لحامله الطائرات هذه البالغ طولها 335
مترا استيعاب 90 طائره يفترض ان تتوجه
حامله الطائرات الى الدائره القطبيه
الشماليه مع بدء مناورات جويه تجمع حوالي
طائره من اربع عشره دوله في التاسع
والعشرين من مايو في هذه المنطقه
وتتشارك النرويج مع روسيا 198 كيلو مترا
من الحدود البريه في اقصى الشمال بالاضافه
الى حدود طويله في بحرز السفاره الروسيه
في اوسلو نددت بوصول حامله الطائرات فورد
وقالت نظرا الى ان اسلو اقرت بان روسيا لا
تشكل تهديدا عسكريا مباشرا للنرويج فان
مثل هذا الاستعراض للقوه يبدو ضارا وغير
منطقي حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من لندن
اندريه
محلل الاستراتيجيه العسكريه في الفريق
الدولي لدراسات الامن سيد اندري ماذا نفهم
من هذه الاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه الذي يبدو
الناتو انه مصر على افهامها وارسال
الرساله بش انها لروسيا
اولا شكرا على الاستفاضه
استضافه عفوا نحن يجب ان ننظر الى الامور
من منظور معين
الصوت يتقطع من المصدر
صوت المتحدث ضعيف من المصدر
للاسف للاسف يبدو انه هناك مشكله في الصوت
لا تصل للزميل المترجم سنكتفي بهذا القدر
اشكرك
كارفالو وحلل استراتيجيه العسكريه في
الفريق الدولي لدراسات
وعذرا على هذا الخلل شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
التضامن والمساعده ندين لهم ابارقه امل
للمستقبل هذا يعني التحرك الفوري لضمان
بقائهم على قيد الحياه والامل كل الامل ان
يقف العالم الى جوار الملايين من سكان هذه
المنطقه لتجاوز محنتهم
حصاد هذه الليله انتهى شكرا لمتابعتكم
دمتم بخير والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]